gut der ist das tentakel die angela wie
angela gezogen
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
meinem ersten fifa 13 mio
ich hab ja in dem konto nummer 1 schon
gesagt ja ich werde demnächst auch fifa
13 videos machen weil ich den kanal ein
wenig von microsoft darüber
transportieren will zu auch ein paar
anderen spielen das heißt nicht dass sie
jetzt de abonniert nur weil jetzt auch
andere spiele kommen das kommt noch
genauso viel minecraft wie sonstige
parteien ordne dingens aufgenommenen app
review also macht euch da gar keine
sorgen ich werde nur ab und zu auch noch
fifa hochladen
das heißt bevor ihr jetzt display und
sagst du von wegen fifa das interessiert
mich gar nicht dann einfach wegklicken
oder halt auch anschauen es mir egal und
ich werde ultimate team spielen und zwar
werde ich wahrscheinlich mal ab und
zusammen papac openings einfach nur hoch
laden als jetzt nicht all zu viel
vielleicht mal ab und zusammen online
spiel was ich dann filme nach
kommentieren wenn es ganz cool war als
jetzt nicht all zu viel schief also
macht euch jetzt nicht in rosé bekommt
jetzt nicht jeden tag von 14 millionen
fifa videos sondern halt nur ab und an
mal ein paar sachen also das finde ich
dann schon ganz witzig und medial was
kann ich euch jetzt hier zu sagen ich
bin nicht so ganz super in fifa also in
ultimate team ich habe mir heute an der
tanke beziehungsweise keine ahnung das
video seht also ich hab mir heute
jedenfalls für 25 euro eine paysafecard
geholt habe da von mir dann wieder einen
psn dings geholt hat mir davon eins
gekauft bleiben diese fifa points und
darüber seht ihr meine münzen das sind
ungefähr acht 1994 als ich ungefähr
sondern ziemlich genau mein verein heißt
conunit ich kann mich immer eben eine
aktive mannschaft zeigen da sind zur
zeit dabei affeley dann habe ich oben im
sturm also links habe ich oben drin habe
ich alexander esswein rechts daneben
kuba also blaszczykowski dann im
mittelfeld gündogan dinge wie heißt ja
nicht renato augusto m
luiz gustavo auf der linken seite elia
auf der rechten seite shaqiri
dann habe ich in der abwehr werden dass
der pr habe ich glaube ich hier den habe
ich neu gekauft ein fittes santana und
diesen gegner oder wieder heißt was ich
kann kurz gucken selassie heißt der so
und torwart rene adler dann welche
baumann tasci friedrich holtby kießling
pizarro kehl und hermann als ich quatsch
vielleicht erst ein paar mal neben dem
mikro her das ist ganz einfach weil der
fernseher rechts steht und mein
bildschirm vorne das heißt kann schon
mal ein paar mal passieren
so jedenfalls ist das wo mein team ich
habe eine 3 4 3 formation blablabla
chemie 100 usw
jedenfalls wollte ich heute zum ersten
mal fällt diese komischen jumbo packs
öffentlich hat man die opec treffen also
nie so joop ex die gibt es heute immer
dienstags von 18 bis 19 uhr gibt es
diese jumbo packs und dachte mir okay
ganze tier 300 fifa points kosten
das heißt wir werden heute mal so ein
paar sachen öffnen ich denke mal kurz
mal mikros ein bisschen damit ihr
zugucken können so nani
na das ist doch mal ein ganz guter
anfang oder moment wartet dann haben wir
da nie ach du hast aber schöne also nah
nieder da freue ich mich jetzt schon so
ein bisschen ist ganz guter spieler
ich packte ihn einfach in die aktive
mannschaft also ich freu mich schon so
ein bisschen jedenfalls nani okay im
ersten tag noch nie drin dort haben wir
sonst noch so diesmal hatte ich habe mir
nebenbei ich kann mal kurz die im
internet gucken
ich habe hier so eine komische data
webseite kann ich mal ganz kurz gucken
wie viel kostet nani also falls mehr so
ein bisschen dahin getorkelt wie so ein
blog oder so was habe ich da sonst noch
alter der tempo 94 wtf
ok also sucht mal ganz kurzen nicht nina
suche nach nina lingani
also nani kostet durchschnittlich auf
der place spiel das auf der place ich
heißt lieblings bei playstation com traf
dani kostet 56.000 ja kein ding ich
ziehe den war einfach so ist das geil
kiefer so weit wäre es das nah sinkt
sinkt okay da sinkt der kostet 77 er
kostet auf 900 ich packe den office mein
verein also wie ihr seht meine aktive
mannschaft also ich packte ihn die
aktiven mannschaften die wird sich noch
ein bisschen füllen ich werde
wahrscheinlich beiden spanisches team
machen übrigens was vorhin gesagt habe
konkret heißt sich bei fifa nur die
sache ist was die sache kann ich alle
verkaufen sofort verkaufen breuer alles
nicht verträge sprechen ich mir
grundsätzlich immer ab weil ich weiß
irgendwann habe ich wieder keine
verträge der musiker so komische
verträge darauf bieten ich heiße bei
playstation kraft nicht konkret derweil
links und geiler faker hat mir den namen
weggenommen
ich freue mich also anmelden wollten
kontrast an denn auf einmal der name
bereits vergebener dass mir so cool
tolle leute hier am start
naja egal jedenfalls borussia dortmund
wappen scheiß fallen tut mir leid aber
mag ich nicht an mich erinnert alles
verkaufen feuer nicht porto brauche ich
nicht den kann ich mir meinen verein
packen und nein ich hab ihn fallen 70
leute soll torwart trainer so den rest
verkauf ich alles 8500 minister für den
rest ok gut ich werde mal heute wie
viele packs werde ich öffne ich weiß
nicht das soll noch nicht allzu lange
gehen fifa wird dass die säulen 13 20
minuten bleiben so wenn man gleich noch
eins ich hoffe mal ich hab wieder glück
möchte ich öffnen so wen haben wir denn
da drin
msi drin ist dann häufig ich hab gar
nicht hingeguckt drin ist wo verträge
auch ryan giggs ist auch ganz cool
glaube ich wie viel wie viel kostet 10 k
ich weiß gar nicht so genau
ich glaube der kostet gar nicht mehr so
viel weil er ist auch gar nicht mehr so
gut 8 800 kostet auf playstation adriano
tempo 30 39 das ist ja geil der
situation so pummelig aus
naja ok hier sind adriano in form von
barcelona sicherte ich komme übrigens
mal bei foot witz dort kommen ok 600
kann man ihn verkaufen ja den brauche
ich nicht was ich liste den einfach mal
für 600 km h schnell verkaufen für 600
von ryan giggs dribbling ist ganz gut
aber eigentlich brauche ich den noch
nicht beim wie teuer weil er jetzt
naja 700 ist jetzt auch nicht so toll
kann ich für sechs mal wieder verkaufen
bräunig so los komm mal nachgucken los
kopf glaubt er ist auch nicht so toll
der kann eigentlich nicht sein tempo 50
tempus wirklich das beste er der 600
wert war lehrer
ich gucke mittlerweile wirklich immer
alle spieler nach wenn ich hier packs
hier ganz einfach aus dem grund weil ich
damals den fehler gemacht habe ich hatte
in silber spielern glänzenden der gkv
hier habe ich rein gesetzt op s 300 und
400 oder so wie wir gar nicht ihr
verkaufen wir auch 300er ich hatte
damals den spielern silber spieler ich
es macarthur und das war halt einfach so
ich hatte den und der kostet irgendwie
2k und ich hab dir vertrauen eingesetzt
ich dachte da silva spieler krieg nicht
viel für denkste der war sofort weg für
den preis weil man lässt das noch nicht
kapiert hat so also ich gucke die ganze
zeit im internet weil ich keine lust
habe dass die alle für unnötig geld
vergeben kieler cassano 300 trainer
bräunig sport fitness nicht verträgen
mittlerweile ist es echt so dass man so
ein bisschen so wie jetzt so als brauche
ich jetzt auch nicht alles verkaufen
die spiel- und ihr team seit fifa 13
seit einer woche ja seit ziemlich genau
einer woche objekt habe ich auch schon
fast fertig wo gott da muss gleich ein
paar sachen anwenden also noch nicht so
lange und dafür bin ich eigentlich schon
ganz zufrieden mit meinem spiel
die formation brauche ich auch nicht so
dass wir ja nicht ganzen rest verkaufen
3000 für den ganzen rest das auch schon
gut naja ok also happy hour ist echt
immer ganz geil sein
sie war direkt
noch song pack 3 100 points ist da nix
sind noch eins wenn der messe drin ist
heilig ich habe schon wieder nicht
hingeguckt immer in dem moment wo der
sohn später auf blinkt gucke ich gerade
auf einem zweiten bildschirm wo das bild
hier angezeigt wird
ich habe nein ich bin in mein team sorgt
alter hut ich habe er sie gewürgt
aber geld untereinander sven sturm alter
der jetzt auch richtig kellerbar ich
liebe dieses spiel alter özil mann ist
der wert 80.000 ich weiß es gar nicht
alter das ist schon krass
es ist es ist schon krass alter findet
der egal ich stehe ich gar nicht mesut
kann einfach mesut özil
ok mesut özil kostet auf der plate hat
ihr angeblich kein preis weiß nicht
warum mesut özil kostet glaube ich zu 80
km
ich weiß gar nicht den packt einfach
eine aktive mannschaft leisten ich hab
den coaches oder so nicht bitte euch
also sachen verkaufen werde ich jetzt
erstmal aktive city maßvoll so hernandez
speicher ich mir erstmal verein den
verein oder ich packe denen die aktive
mannschaft und tauscht den gegen anderen
spieler den ich dann einfach raus kicker
oder so dein verein blickt bei support
der klaviatur
den habe ich denn hier so stürmer die
ich nicht mehr brauche ja kommt kießling
brauche ich nicht das nicht so toll
dies legen schnell verkauf jako nahe
halle sich sehr gut oder wie viel ist
der wert ich weiß nur dass der schnell
ist und schnelligkeit ist eigentlich
alles beim ultimate team didier ya konan
also nicht fürchten raushauen ultimate
team
db punkt an ell player database so
moment schon mal ganz kurz nach didier
ya konan fehler ja schön ich lasse mir
erstmal habe ich hier sonst noch so
schlecht schlecht torwart brauche ich
erstmal nicht hab ich ja hildebrand
blabla verträge könnte ich mir noch ein
paar reinhauen zudem noch da müsste ich
das bald wieder aus dem verkauf die
sachen ihre schwester hat gar nicht wie
viel ich in meinem verein allgemein 85
kann ich dann noch ein paar mehr kann
ich einpacken moral
flm das ist auch noch gut das lässt sich
nur einfach für 1000 würde ich sagen ja
schon ob da aufbietet
da kam eine stunde paar schon anbieten
kann ich alles ähnliche komischen ball
seifert ich finde ich jetzt einmal so
ein paar sachen an
dann schaue ich mir das wert in den
schlechter moral so der hat eine
schlechte nacht komplettes team oder wie
hätte es nicht so viel gefasst so wartet
die seite jetzt fertig geladen zur jagd
runde klappte das auch nicht mehr wert
als 7 300 oder so
392 spiele training
wer braucht denn vielleicht training
geboren ein bisschen der lieblings 93 99
tempo alter hat er jetzt mittlerweile
wenn wir das ist schon krass wieder
training fitness könnte ich wenig in
fitness geben
ich glaube kilogramm erhalten die so
lang durch bei mir auch so dass jetzt
auch noch für den moment naja ok gut da
machen wir heute mal eine lange folge
fifa da mache ich jetzt immer nur
solange folgen fifa würde ich sagen weil
ich hätte nie gedacht dass es so lange
dauert wenn ich in ein paar sachen mache
hier afellay sehr sehr guter mann apfel
linksaußen müsste um form ich glaube den
linken mittelfeld ist auf jeden fall
sehr sehr geil spielervertrag wenn ich
sofort auf asyl an
ich denke ich jetzt mal ein paar runden
mit denen und danach kann ich den ja
immer noch verkaufen alter siehe links
linda mitte nani links und rechts planen
wie shaqiri oder so dass schon geil
ich freue mich gerade so richtig
hässlich wie viel becks sich als hier
müssten einfach in die kommentare
schreiben also alle die jetzt wirklich
immer noch zuschauen an euch erstmal
danke dass ihr hier seid und eventuell
ja so viel würde ich auf jeden fall auch
noch länger halten der ist einfach nur
richtig geil
eventuell weniger lange folgen fifa
haben wollt oder eher kurz zu sagen also
eher kurzes perso 15
und er lang würde ich jetzt zu sagen 30
40 minuten weil ich bin der mittlerweile
auch schon bei 13 minuten müssten wir
dann einfach mal miteinander vereinbaren
wie ihr das haben wollt so der hat noch
vergeblich nani noch ein bisschen wird
20 ich meine ich habe jetzt zeit doch
eigentlich keine geldnot so bei fifa sag
ich mal setzt sich eingebildet
rüberkommen aber es ist bei mir jetzt
nicht so dass ich sage jetzt muss ich
aber ja sparen jetzt kann ich aber keine
packs mehr öffnen klub weil so viel wie
ich zurzeit fifa spieler da passt das
eigentlich schon dass ich da ab und zu
mal so ein paar pack openings machen
kann
ach so der manager dann bleibt er halt
auch noch ein bisschen ich habe schon
gedacht mir jogi löw als manager zu
kaufen ich glaube das macht jetzt nicht
allzu groß unterschied zu den rest
verkaufen war 2000 passt so die man noch
ein peg peg ja oder nein schnick schnack
schnuck ich gegen mich okay gewonnen
300 points öffne ich mal essen da so
drin schon wieder ryan giggs ist ein
duplikat warte das muss man ganz kurz
gucken für die pflichten anbieten kann
der kostet nur 1000 auf fairplay sie als
zmf den vorhin als linkes mittelfeld
gezogen und wird jedoch unter duplikat
fallen so matthew übrigens valencia
heute an dem abend heute ist der
zwanzigste elfte spielt bayern gegen
valencia
denn sonst noch so daniel er ist auch
ganz gut
ich weiß nicht wie viel ist der wert ich
schau mal ganz kurz danilo fairplay
canori sein als ob dennis ein bisschen
wertes an die das ist der 77er rechter
verteidiger
der kostet nämlich 1100
seitdem erhalten immer näher kommt aus
brasilien empfahl der hawaii gesehen
hatte ich gucke erst mal kurz im verein
habe ich damals sachen im verein halo
tsx.v stapel bla verbrauchs objekte sind
falls ja wie kann ich denn im verein
gucken dann würde ich jetzt eben noch
ein paar verträge an wänden oder ein
paar verträge verkaufen
z oo auf ms den habe ich den citroën da
habe ich sie sehe könnte ich ja dann
theoretisch bis ich verkaufe hier ein
paar verträge hat also dass alles
schnell verkaufen bleibt 84 habe ich da
jetzt training oder ich nehme einfach
und ich werde einfach mal so ein paar
sachen an als ich denke das wird erstmal
das letzte pack für heute gewesen sein
weil ich bin jetzt auch nicht so ein typ
der hier die ganze zeit runter und drauf
alles anwendet was man irgendwie so
haben kann also alles mögliche wieder
verkauft oder so ich will da schon so
ein bisschen planen für die zukunft sage
ich mal ein paar sachen verkaufe ich
jetzt schon schnell verkauf schnell
verkauft
schnell verkauft ganzen blöden trainings
sachen ich meine wenn ich jetzt
mittlerweile bald einen großen kader hat
dann bringt mir die komplette finden ist
sie auch eigentlich nix moral könnte ich
noch ein bisschen was nehmen so 77
punkten löwel fast erstmal die ganzen
modifikationen hier die brauche ich auch
nicht so schnell verkauft moralwächter
verhalten mein gott schnell verkauft so
neue objekte 24 alter so ryan giggs ich
liste den einfach jetzt mal für 1000
schon auf deiner dorfbild oder
startpreis sagen wir mal 700 sofort
kaufen 1100 eine stunde objekt anbieten
matthew oder matten match natürlich
wisse nicht er kommt aus frankreich
deswegen würde ich eher sagen martin
hermann kurz gucken mathieu spielt bei
valencia in spanien kommt aus frankreich
ich weiß nicht wie viele verwehrt ist
aber jogi löw ist jeden fall bisschen
was werd ich packte dann wenn die aktive
mannschaft auf man jetzt ich hab zwar
gerade seinen vertrag verlängert aber
jogi löw ist das schon ein bisschen
geiler so schnell verkauft also materie
wie heißt er denn kommt dort fragen
gleich gespielt der später verletzte
also da ja okay jetzt 800 wert die
wirklich in ihr verkaufen will für 600
verkaufen kann
okay gut passt dann ist auch nicht so
viel wert ich packt erstmal im verein
kommen die verkäufer schnell paar
verträge blabla 18 13 den kann ich noch
im verein packen sind ich packe ich im
verein
ich packe ich einfach ein manager
vertrag kann ich mir nachher immer noch
kaufen wenn der löwen wie man keinen
bock mehr auf mich hat manager formation
352 es blöd blöd blöd amsterdamarena ich
hab wembley rolfe ist unser dingens
trainer torwart-trainer brauche ich
nicht kaufe ich die ganze sache mal so
ich würde sagen wir ziehen jetzt noch
einen pack weil wir sind jetzt schon
fast bei 20 minuten
so 301 pack ziehen wir uns noch wen
haben wir denn miquel irgendwas falcao
wenn die verkaufsorder alter werden
fasst viele glänzende sachen und keinen
glänzenden spieler gut der ist das
tentakel angela damit die ag lage zurück
okay okay eigentlich nur aktuell plano
den ruhig mal kurz plano wie vieles der
wm ok 300 und der galerie so es mit
gesängen man schauen findet er nicht
interessant mit einem bindestrich
da seien auch 300 gut der kommt aus
deutschland das ist schon mal ganz cool
ich bin bei unterhaching hatten der 75
warum kennt nicht ihnen ein wenig 74
tempo außerdem kann man bestimmt
irgendwas gutes machen aber darf ich
gott kein interesse drin
ok haben erst ein paar gute verträge
drin ich glaube den vertrag wenn ich
hier direkt auf özil manager vertrag
auflösen ist auf jeden fall immer gut
direkt auf jogi löw da 35 spieler kann
nämlich trainieren so fitness packt nur
noch rein was sind das für die
modifikation position ok ist auf el a
brauche ich bestimmt mal 4 428 das ist
manager ach man ich denke schon ich
ziehe so weil sonst ist die ungefähr 8 k
so wertet staging was ich brauche
eigentlich prager würde trikots bei der
sks verkaufen bisschen was ich glaube
ich sie noch in pec den vertrag sprechen
normal da drin
die ganzen spiele brauche eigentlich
alle gleich okay gut den rest verkaufe
ich jetzt eben 2400 und dieses set ist
nicht mehr verfügbar
ach so weil man nur ein paar täglich
ziehen kann ist da wat dann können uns
jetzt noch sogar ein pack da ist zwar
jetzt wahrscheinlich nichts gutes drin
so
aber schauen wir einfach mal locker
kenne ich nicht meine dachte man kann
mehr öffnen guckt da ist jeder die sache
so panetta barnetta packe ich mir den
verein weil er spielt in deutschland das
ganz gut für meine ich nie locker der
walker ach so locker also der hat 91
tempo das ist geil
das kann schon mal sagen die krone
beulich den crew ist dass dieser kyle
walker sind
das ist der der kostet 44 k
bei mir weil ich will dem paket wird die
abwehr führte zu gelb so wirklich dafür
raushauen ich habe hier immer noch ein
rechtsverteidiger bei den den will ich
ihm noch verhaltene friere ich den
brauch ich nicht mehr für den mache ich
schnell verkauft so wieder zur tür rein
den wollte ich noch nachgucken und zwar
bin ich immer ganz vorsichtig jetzt bei
diesem letzten silber spiel und warum
habe ich schon gesagt gonzales spielt in
españa bei rvm weist als wert verliert
niemals mit adrian da adrian ja auch 300
wehrt den ball jetzt nicht unbedingt
klar oberkörper trainer so dichter
reinpacken den wenn du dich eben mal an
brauchs objekt anwenden
reicht das mich im vernünftigen auf den
jubilar fachleute mein team ich bin so
froh wahrscheinlich am ganz viele von
euch bessere teams oder so aber ich bin
schon froh über mein team blog schnee
schlief so längeren vertrag bekommt auf
jeden fall jetzt dieser komische fritzl
der walker als verteidiger 93 tempo das
ist schon das ist schon krass abwehr
training wisst ihr was ich wenn ich ein
paar sachen hier an
wenn ich den locker hier schon hab da
haben wir dann kriegt er noch ein
bisschen abwehr trainings auf 94 nativen
791 tempo das ist das ist heftig fitness
wer braucht denn hier hat er durch
du siehst bisschen erschöpft aus so weiß
sonst auch etwas kann ich den gegen die
an wänden verein speichern kann ich hier
nur den rest will ich aber verkaufen so
600 es war ganz gut dass wir noch ein
pack gezogen haben wir locker ist auf
jeden fall 4,4 k wert da kann man schon
mal so ein bisschen was rausreißen so
dann würde ich sagen was das mit meinem
ersten fifa video
ich kann euch meine mannschaft ja jetzt
mal zeigen dass er mit 22 k münzen und
noch ein paar points die bewahre ich mir
aber für die nächste findet die nächste
happy aber am nächsten dienstag um 18
uhr wieder auf dass mein jetziges team
auf dem bin ich sehr stolz auf den
walker den händlern des den mag ich sehr
nani und natürlich auch özil ich finde
das so geil dass ich den hut dribbling
88 alter jetzt der beste mein name
dribbeln kann auch gut dribbeln und sam
auch aber der prozess ist schon geil
na ja gut das war es erstmal auch so ich
wollte jetzt umstellen die so ein
bisschen
da kann natürlich jetzt nicht gut
spielen da kann er auch nicht gut spiele
ich weiß ich habe ich die formation
allgemeinen auch um stelle ob ich dazu
lasse vielleicht kann ich dir doch
einfach noch auspacken die das auch
nicht gut
egal jedenfalls würde ich sagen dass wir
uns dann beim nächsten mal wiedersehen
beim nächsten fifa video könnt ihr
verbesserungsvorschläge und so weiter
die kommentare schreiben
und dann würd ich sagen wir sehen und
beim nächsten mal bewerten nicht
vergessen wenn irgendwie 100 oder 200
leicht schaffen jetzt auf jeden fall
ganz cool weil dann weiß ich dass euch
das hier gefällt was ich hier mache
übrigens guckt euch mal die werte von
esswaren an tempo 90
das ist schon krass für sonst immer vom
ersten fc nürnberg nehmen
naja ok gut wir sehen es beim nächsten
mal haue der einläutet